>>Tonia: Let's keep that
good concentration going.
>>Girl: They cleared land
by cutting down forests.
>>Tonia: All four turn
out, one big chop.
Good job!
>>Tonia: Because our students use the
arts to deepen their understanding,
they remember content for a longer
period of time, and they're able
to use their voice, their
body, their art skills
to demonstrate knowledge
in the way that is fun.
>>Teacher: Here we go.
[drumming]
>>Jessica: Having the
arts as a core part
of our academic program was
critical to our founders.
We've seen the arts as
important for two reasons.
One is because they are beautiful
and joyful in and of themselves.
But the other reasons is we think that
kids can arrive at new understandings
about other content areas
through their work in art.
>>Leah: You want to be
thinking about colors--
>>Tonia: Students are either
integrating Social Studies content
with an Arts discipline, or Science
content with an Arts discipline.
The Art Staff and classroom
teachers look
at the guiding questions,
what the big ideas are.
So there's just a lot of
discussion, a lot of collaboration.
>>Sharanya: The four forces
help an airplane to fly.
>>Sharanya: This semester our expedition
is about the physics of flight.
The goal is for students to learn
about how airplanes fly in the air.
>>Stuart: Our problem is people
at the National Airport don't
understand the physics of fight,
even though they're about
to get on planes.
>>Paz: We're going to put
up arts at the airport,
so people can know what the
four forces of flight are
like lift, gravity, thrust and drag.
>>Leah: Thinking about using our
four forces, we can use paintbrushes,
we can even do a little bit of pouring.
>>Leah: So we begin with Jackson
Pollock and some of his artwork,
and kids realize pretty quickly
that he's using the four forces.
They see him using gravity and thrust
in his really active style of painting.
And they start trying it out.
>>Leah: And what force will
you be using as you're pouring?
>>Girl: Gravity.
>>Leah: So yeah, when you poured it,
it didn't just go out into the air.
>>Girl: Gravity pulled it down.
>>Leah: That was gravity.
>>Ethan: Jackson Pollock
used forces like drag
because when there was a big puddle
of paint, and some paint went
through the big blob of
paint, it slowed down,
because that blob of paint was bigger.
>>Boy: That is so cool!
>>Leah: All right!
Good job!
>>Leah: It's really just about making
those abstract concepts concrete.
>>Leah: What if we do
a little bit of this?
>>Ethan: I like art and science,
so I'm doing two things I
like to learn how something works.
>>Leah: You guys had
a great contribution.
I'm loving it.
>>Sharanya: With these art experiments,
it's something they could hold onto
and point to and say,
"Here's how a force works,
and I was able to do that myself."
>>Leah: Great job today, guys!
>>Tonia: All right!
Here we go, action.
>>Class: There is a river
that tells a story.
>>Alex: So this semester, we're
learning about the Anacostia River,
and all of like the problems
and things going wrong
with it, like all the pollution.
>>Alex: It is a story of the
community's efforts to save it.
>>Tonia: They were using an anchor
text in their classroom called,
"A River Ran Wild," which
is a true story
about the Nashua River in Massachusetts.
And they were using that to help
build students' background knowledge.
And we decided to let
that be their drama piece.
>>Tonia: Step back upstage, high five.
Natives come downstage and--
>>Tonia: We just started acting it out,
playing around with the characters,
and it just kind of just
started gelling together.
>>Tonia: Shoot!
>>Tonia: And so we put all of
our ideas from playing with it
in class into one organized script.
>>Boy: This is a story about
people who made a difference!
>>Tonia: Good!
>>Bryn: It's teaching you
through something more fun,
so you can like learn more
through something like active.
>>Tonia: Pose like you're
overcome with grief and sadness.
Crying...
>>Tonia: When you put movement
to text, it helps you have
to think about it much more deeply.
Kids have to make intentional choices
about how they're going
to use their voice.
How they're going to use their body.
How they're going to depend on
one another to relate the story.
>>Bryn: And slowly the Nashua's
fish grew sick from the pollution.
>>Tonia: Let's do that again, Wilson.
That might just be the
showstopper right there.
>>Bryn: Through the play we were
showing that if they can clean
up the Nashua River, then we
can clean up the Anacostia,
so people know you can
make a difference.
>>Tonia: Give Wilson a hand!
[clapping]
>>Leah: When they recognize something
they've been studying in their classroom
in this new environment, their
faces just really light up,
and you know that's going
to stick with them.
>>Leah: Arm created.
>>Leah: They're not going
to forget that,
that's an experience that is going deep.
>>Class: New York!
>>Tonia: Whoo-hoo!
Yes! [claps]